vous vous moquez de moi 3 veut
particulièrement simple et en théorie
sans aucun risque j'ai été emprisonné
par salomon justement parce que j'ai
crié haut et fort ce que mon coeur
désiré je ne pourrais gagner ma
libération qu en exauçant vous souhait
mais j'apprécie c'est très poétique mais
le fait est qu en ce qui concerne ma vie
je ne peux vraiment pas trouvé un seul
voeu intéressant alors comment formuler
trouille hâtive de la vie en vous
êtes-vous vivante savez vous que dans
certaines cultures l'absence de désir
signifie elle enchante vous êtes vieux
et idiot mais si je suis satisfaite
pourquoi tant tel destin et vous cette
loge ne me provoquer pas il n'existe
aucun humain aucun os aucun jean qui ne
voudraient avoir la chance de satisfaire
ses plus grand désir je me retrouverai
avec la seule qui prétendent en avoir
aucun invité à bini vous êtes une
menteuse vous savez qu'elle veut je
devrais faire savoir
[Musique]